Oh this observe one another.
They observe people and they represent
what they see and they transmit the
message of what they see to
us and they teach us to see,
and we don't necessarily know what
it is that we're learning from them,
but we're learning something.
Or at least we're acting like
we're learning something.
We go to movies,
we watch stories,
we,
we immerse ourselves
in fiction constantly.
That's an artistic production.
And for many people,
the world of the arts is a living world.
And that's particularly true if you're
a creative person and it's the creative,
artistic people that do move the
knowledge of humanity forward.
And they do that with their
artistic productions first.
They're on the edge and
the dancers do that.
And the poets do that.
And the visual artists do that in the
musicians do that and we're not sure what
they're doing.
Like we're not sure what
musicians are doing,
what the hell are they doing?
Why do you like music?
You know,
it gives you deep intimation
of the significance of
things and no one questions
it.
You go to a concert,
you're thrilled.
It's a quasi religious experience,
particularly if the people really get
themselves together and get the crowd
moving.
You know,
there's something
incredibly intense about it,
but it makes no sense whatsoever.
It's not an easy thing to understand.
Music is deeply patterned and I,
and patterned in layers.
And I think that has something to do
with it because reality is pattern and
deeply patterned in layers.
And so I think music is representing
reality in some fundamental way,
and that we get into the sway of that
and sort of participate in being,
and that's part of what makes
it such an uplifting experience,
but we don't really know
that's what we're doing.
We just go do it.
And,
and,
and it's nourishing for people,
right?
I mean,
young people in particular that
lots of them live for music.
It's where they derive all their meaning,
their cultural identity,
everything that's nourishing comes from
their affiliation with their music is
part of their cultural identity.
So that's an amazing thing.